j'aurais revenir juste sur le
nutri-score voilà un outil qui au départ
me paraissait extrêmement formidable
quand on s'intéresse à l'alimentation et
finalement très opaque pour le
simplicitoyen c'est à dire que je viens
de regarder comme ça avant de venir ce
matin
nutri-score B sur des nuggets donc vous
ne connaissez pas du tout le sourcing du
produit et nous triscore a sur du
roquefort ou sur 100 g d'huile d'olive
vous voyez que c'est compliqué de pas
ramener les choses à la portion aussi
parce que sur 100 g de nuggets c'est 100
g de olive qui va boire 100 g d'huile
d'olive ou qui va manger 100 g de
roquefort à la fois et c'est aussi
l'aide qu'on peut donner à porter au
consommateurs avec des nutri-score qui
soit vraiment détrisco d'une efficacité
redoutable vous savez quand on comparait
à kilo de sucre et une bouteille de soda
ça ça parle aux mamans et au papa qui
achètent en disant la tête que j'exagère
et si ramener ce nutriscore pour
l'adapter à des publics qui des fois
n'ont pas l'analyse et on peut le
comprendre de
valoriser